so I want thank man for the invitation
it's great to be here so over the last
four or five years the the main emphasis
of our lab was really not so much trying
to understand learning of internal
models a recalibration of internal
models but trying to understand how
humans are able to learn real novel and
complex motor behaviors like playing the
piano and also through functional
imaging work to understand how those
skills are represented in the hierarchy
of cortical motor regions now so really
coming here accepting his in radiation I
was feeling all that ambiguous about
that that I really didn't have so much
to say about internal moles per se now
what I want to do though is not talk
about the main emphasis of our work over
the last few years but to present you
small series of behavioral studies that
I think speak to this interesting
problem of a calibration of interim also
recalibration of internal models on one
side as we further in need so tell stock
and Collins talk today and on the other
hand the question of what happens when
that's not no longer enough and when
recalibration of an existing internal
model cannot get you the behaviors that
you really need to implement to do
something like for example by michaela
so let me start with again redefining
what what we understand where we say
internal model it's kind of a slippery
slope here in general the purpose of the
nervous system is to take some goal
state and to then send feed-forward
commands motor commands to the body and
also use sensory feedback to do feedback
control to achieve that goal so this is
really the general general layout of
what what nervous systems are for now
when we'd say internal model or we kind
of conjure up is a internal architecture
that consists of something that we can
control policy that that sense or
compute these motor commands but that is
based now critically on some neuro
representation that represents the body
or the outside world
and this representation is not just fed
through the incoming sensory information
but also fed through thumb to some
internal prediction that is made by
something that that we would call a
forward model now from pure behavior is
actually astonishingly difficult to kind
of find really waterproof evidence that
this is actually the computation that is
performed but I want to focus today on
one of the I think telltale signs that
that such a model is actually exists or
is implemented in the nervous system and
that's the ability of the system to take
sensory prediction errors so the
discrepancy between some in flowing
sensory information and the prediction
that the nervous system made um and use
that prediction to sell how modify its
motor behavior right on the next trial
and that is a very very difficult
problems term the inverse problem of
motor control let me just show you that
this is actually not a trivial
computation now imagine you are one of
the subjects in one of the many motor
control laboratories in around the world
that implemented paradigm like this
where you're asked to sit in front of a
robotic device you're asked to reach
with your hand to target and you don't
see your hand but you get some visual
feedback on some screen and your the
position of your hand is marked with the
cousin so you reached your target and
then on some trials the cursor actually
moves in an unexpected way so here moves
when your hand moves slightly left the
cursor move slightly to the right so you
have an error and the question is well
what do you do now what what should we
do on the next movement now in most
motor control laboratory you would
actually be correct in inferring that
what the experiments experimenter did
was to rotate the visual feedback by
some certain degree around the origin so
here in this case at the 40 degree
rotation of the curves of feedback in
respect to the hand and so the logical
thing on the next trial what you should
do is you should move a little bit
further to the left so that the cursor
again rotated would go a little bit
closer to the time you repeat that a
couple of times and after a few trials
you would actually be able to achieve
the target again and ultimately
the experiment get out of it now that's
not the only response that that you
could do it could also be true that the
experimenter maliciously didn't do a
visual rotation but actually mirror the
visual display around the midsagittal
axis so when the hand goes to the left
the Kurds would go to the right and if
their end goes to the right the cursor
we go to the left now in this situation
on this single trial that you might see
the result is exactly the same your hand
goes to the left the car goes to the
right you have exactly the same error
but now the response of going to the
left would make matters worse so the way
if you were to go to the left here the
current that would actually go further
to the right and miss the target even
more the right response of course is to
oops alright so frozen with generally
so the right response would be actually
to go further to the right so bring the
cursor closer difficult so now really
nice work by at an EVO pets group has
shown that subjects confronted with this
ambiguous situation very strongly
respond in a way that indicates that
they understand these perturbations as
visual rotations so you can model this
is kind of a patient prior on a
parametric space or to think that this
internal model makes some structural
assumption about the world to understand
this ambiguity in the sensory arrow that
then guides the way we're done and so
what I want to ask today is if the
current internal model that subjects
have in their brain actually prefers or
more of the world as being consistent of
of visual feedback that might have a
visual mode of rotation what do subjects
do and how do they react when they're
confronted with me reversal said kind of
defies the current internal model and
forces them to really implement
something what happens so here's a very
simple experiment I was a very boring
experiment but we just had people for
four days straight reach to a target
straight ahead okay and this is done
with a robotic device and and because of
the anisotropy of the device you see
that they reach for the reached on which
totally straight the reach of little bit
curve to the left here way so you see
this 2.5 degree arrow and average in the
baseline trials now we do then is we
mirror the visual feedback and when you
reach straight you shouldn't really see
it but what they see is a small error on
the screen that goes now two and a half
degrees to the right now subjects
actually understand that error as a
visual motor rotation and following the
current internal model start to doubt do
you see actually what they do they go
further to the left um making the matter
actually worse and increasing the error
rough way until they had about 15
degrees error on the screen they go in
the wrong direction initiative now then
something happens and over the next four
days they kind of turn around and start
adapting to this to this visual motor
rotation and ultimately are pretty able
to reach straight and also get the
variability down again
now the key question I want to ask is
what happens at that moment where they
seem to just say well this internal
model isn't working anymore I really
need to do something new what learning
increments are kicking in in that moment
so what could it be now as Mark just
said we when we talk about internal
models we shouldn't just talk about
internal models as one is one internal
model for the whole motor behavior it's
often useful to kind of break it down
into multiple processing steps and so
it's pretty reasonable to assume that
there is some model that translates
visual target information also maybe
visual hand feed back into some plan in
proprioceptive space so knowing where in
proprioceptive space to move the head
and then maybe some internal model that
deals with the dynamics of the arm and
computes the forces and that also then
takes into account proprioceptive
feedback to guide to move now when we
are confronted with an unknown visual
motor error the first reaction is of
course to try to change that kinematic
model and try to change the parameter so
change the computation change the output
so that the response is more appropriate
now these internal models are very well
practiced we've been reaching all our
lives so they are fast and very very
automatic and that can be shown in
various ways so we would assume that if
you recalibrate your internal model you
should inherit that trained automaticity
for the new behavior now what happens
when that fails now we're all humans we
have the ability to learn any arbitrary
stimulus-response association so there's
nothing really that at least when we
take enough time and think about it long
enough that we can't do right nothing
too abstract so one idea is that once
you're really confronted with an error
that really defies your current internal
model maybe engage these processes that
are very slow and voluntary so kind of
response selection processes that you
see a target on the right maybe you know
that the the feedback is my reverse you
suspected your spacing is simply replan
your movements
okay the target on the right I really
need to move my hand to the left and you
might implement that and then feed some
other goal into the dynamic model that
then computes the motor commands um so
so that might that might be how people
actually initially deal with this
perturbation or the idea then is that
that new response selection so re
planning a movement in such a way might
act as a scaffold in a way for the
system to construct possibly a new
internal model that then might make that
that new computation the mirror verse
reaching are more automatic maybe not
reaching the same automaticity of the of
the World Trade models but at least
going faster and faster and faster and
making performance better so that's
that's kind of the bane idea was kind of
the main idea of sebastien tellier was a
PhD student in my lab um so the
prediction really was then that all we
should see when people learning new
internal model establishing you to
internal model that we should see it in
the temporal dynamics of how they plan
it so in the beginning there should be
very slow and then it should
increasingly automobiles so that was his
prediction and that's what we wanted to
test so what he did was he took subjects
and confronted them either with revision
motor rotation or with me reversal
perturbation and restricted their
reaction time so it next to them and
every time they took a reaction time of
longer than 385 millisecond he played a
loud annoying sound to them and they
lost a penny or so of their of their
earnings of the experiment so they were
very motivated to actually move the
reaction times below that cut off now
what happens um so what Sebastian did
was then first of all there are two
potential targets in the upward
direction and he let them reach to one
of the targets and he labeled the errors
now he looks at the reaction time so
here the fastest reaction times around
200 milliseconds at the slowest reaction
time maybe 350 milliseconds you and
break this up and we can label now the
errors that I made and because this is
the mirror versal condition he labeled
the errors in this condition that a
positive when the cursor missed the left
target to the
right there would be a positive error
and when the cursor missed the left or
right target to the left that would also
be a positive error so non-adaptive
going to the old direction would be a
positive there so in black we see here
the baseline block where there's no
visual me reversal in post yet and what
you can see is that the errors aren't
exactly zero in this case and the reason
for this is that we only presented these
two targets and subject kind of knew
that and they knew that that a good
strategy to deal with this reaction time
constraint is to kind of just generally
move up so they have a slight bias for
the left target to move to the right for
the right time to move um but the key
thing is that when we switched on the
mirror reversal this dramatically
changed so what we saw now was first of
all that reaction times dramatically
slowed so they took more time and kind
of got more penalty trials but also that
there was a clear much better than here
speed dependency or time dependency of
the response so for slow reaction times
when they had enough time to think about
it they actually went in the right
direction and reduce their or maybe from
215 degrees so if they if you go to the
old target you would throw an error of
40 degrees more than 20 degrees error
would say that you go actually in the
wrong direction and that's what you see
for reaction times that are faster than
then 30 milliseconds you see that
they're clearly still went in the wrong
direction and then over the course of
the first day you see that that response
starts to automatize and for the same
reaction time you get actually less
error or you get the same error for
shorter reaction times okay when they
come back the next day they actually
moved further after two days of training
you can see that they still didn't reach
quietly automaticity that they had for
the old established mapping but it comes
closer we've trained people now for four
days and the kind of itch is closer and
closer to this black line but it never
quite reaches it now the key comparative
the key comparison is to the visual
motor rotation where we did the same
experiment now the errors are labeled
slightly differently so if you don't
adapt to 40 degree rotation of the
cursor to the left the
a positive error for the right target is
again missing the codes that missing the
target to the left here for the left
target is also now missing to the left
so when we look at the baseline now
these this group actually showed the
same bias at the baseline as this one is
just that we label the arrows here
opposite direction so that averages out
so you see basically no speed dependency
and 0 era on average in this group but
now the key thing is what happens when
we put on the visual motor rotation and
what you see is that there's a clear 20
degree error again the expected error in
the beginning was 40 degrees that
reduces quickly to 20 further to 10
within the same day but you see here
very clearly that there's no significant
difference between the long reaction
time and the short range in time so
there's no speed dependency nothing like
compared t in the mirror force and that
also continues on the second day so we
are very dramatically different speeds
accuracy trade-offs here individual
rotation it seems like no matter how
fast you react there is some automate
all ties process that translates the
target location intermotor plan within
the mirror versal if you don't take
enough time to pre-plan your movement
you are actually going to be much more
inaccurate and be dominated by the old
old old mapping so it seems then
recalibrating this one can use the
established automaticity of the of the
internal model whereas when you start
with something it starts up here in
response selection and then it's
polymerised you might need additional
time for this processing that then
ultimately is automatic now makes an
interesting prediction here because we
think that these internal models are not
just there to take a target and
translate it into some motor command
feed-forward motor command but also
there to take visual hand feedback and
use that to then drive online
corrections during the movement so that
should also be a function of an internal
model that we have and so we should see
the same speed actually trade-offs in
these fast feedback corrections so
that's what we did we want to model that
or study this in the same experiment we
die people and sometimes reach to a
straw gate
to the target straight ahead and then
this place the cursor during the
movement I'm just shifted it over over
very rapid time window here two
centimeters to the right and so what
people do very automatically and very
fast is to correct their movement and
move the hand further to the left to
ultimately bring the cursor over to the
right and one way of measuring these
which which is kind of a nice method
that david franklin introduced into the
field is to constrain the movement to a
straight path directory by putting a
force clamp a so-called force clamp in
it's a programming a robotic device to
constrain the movement to the
straight-line trajectory and simply
measure the force with which the subject
starts to push into that channel so so
this is one of these false traces or the
average for strays in the group but you
can see at zero milliseconds the cursor
starts shifting here and in roughly 110
milliseconds or so 120 you see very
clear response of the arm pushing
towards left to correct to correct for
this error now in the mirror versal this
would be of course the wrong feedback
response so what they should do after
learning the mirror versal is they
should fully reverse that response and
now for target jump to the right they
should push to the right now they never
quite do that so you see within the
first day they still for the whole whole
first day training they still push in
the wrong direction so they always push
to the right they just reuse this
response a little bit and then the end
of the first day at about 300 to 350
milliseconds they just move straight
ahead but early on they still move in
the wrong direction it's only on the
second day that they're able to then
reverse the response and push in the
right in the correct and into the right
direction for this cause of John but
again here you see that this very early
response from a 110 to maybe 11 and 80
milliseconds still is directed in the
wrong direction never quite goes away
even after four days of training I still
little blip here that goes in the wrong
direction and reveals the old map
so in contrast and I'm not showing the
data and engines of time it seems that
under visual rotations and that the
feedback response is slightly harder to
measure but it seems like they're the
the fast feedback responses I
immediately doubled so you adapt your
internal model to visual rotation and
your feedback responses seem to
immediately be adapted to take that
visual mutation into account so to
summarize then both a feed-forward and
feedback control on the mirror over so
we have very parallel time dependency in
those feed forward and feedback comments
so I highlighted here the response
between 250 and 300 milliseconds of the
system so you see here feedback control
allows us we need to measure this video
early responses where and feed forward
control 252 three hours really kind of
the earliest that we can measure but you
can see in both feedback on feed forward
control early in the first day they go
in the wrong direction and the end of
the first day they cancelled out the
error and is only on the second day that
they seem to go in the correct direction
for that for that time winner now we
looked at this data over the time cause
of the training we made it kind of for
us very interesting discovery and we saw
something that that really hasn't been
seen our for teaching reaching movements
to humans namely the evidence for
offline consolidation the evidence that
when you end on the first day and you
come back on the next day it seemed like
it was a climate of jump in your in your
performance you suddenly we're better
coming back the next thing and so that
race T the issue that maybe there is a
different learning mechanism involved
here compared to adaptation and that's
exactly what we see so here is the error
at about 250 milliseconds for the visual
rotation experiment and we see exactly
what you see typically in all adaptation
experiments that I'm aware of that over
the first day people reduce error they
go home they sleep a night at this dash
line and they come back and immediately
they have forgotten something which they
then can we learn rather quickly on the
second day but there's always some
forgetting overnight
in the mirror of versal case we saw in
the one group that we first study that
the error reduced and it seemed then
coming back the next day they
immediately got better and then stayed
at that level for the second day so
something might have happened to a night
now offline gains is a very disputed
phenomenon is kind of hard to measure
this so we weren't quite confident that
that really was quantified a qualified
as good evidence for that so we repeated
this experiment to other groups and so
this this group was tested in the
morning and morning like this group with
the 24 hour break in the sleep of night
of sleep in between this group only had
a 12 hour break trained in the evening
night of sleep and then came back the
next morning you see in all three groups
there was a significant offline gain no
matter how we calculated it in this case
we just took the average of the last
block in the average of the first block
you always saw this job in the feedback
kumon that might not be super in three
forward command this is offline gains in
the feed forward command we saw it even
clearer and the feedback command so we
looked also in the feedback kumar now at
the at the force i were produced in the
same time window around 250 milliseconds
and we can see that they improved their
feedback come on down to zero but then
really took a night of sleep for them to
come back and really go into the right
direction to see very clear evidence for
this downward jump now we thought that
was quite exciting because the only
place that we were aware of that offline
gains in human skill learning where
reported and human learning were
reported are relatively high level of
complex stars in the sequential learning
task so when you learn to type out the
sequence on a keyboard so that in that
seemed like a learning task that is not
cerebellar dependent like visual motor
adaptation but it has much more basic
angular dependence and their people have
argued that they that they see offline
consideration and also sleep dependent
offline conservation and so what's the
first time that we saw this at a
reaching does so we're quite excited
because it argues that there might be
some parallels in the learning
mechanisms that underlie
learning this new control policy for
reaching movements and maybe learning
more other complex task like sequences
now one interesting thing from this
literature is also that these offline
gains are sleep dependent so that depend
actually did that you get a night of
sleep and so we wanted to test this here
so we had already these three groups and
then we tested another group that also
had a 12 hour break like this group but
trained in the morning and then came
back in the evening and you can see that
there is no real forgetting here but you
also see that this offline gain your
product applauded here in this graph in
this group that has a 12 hour break but
no sleep seemed somewhat reduced I have
to be very careful here because the
difference between these three groups in
this group were not surgery is
statistically significant so we did stay
a little bit agnostic here if this
offline gain is really sleep dependent
similarly in the feed forward command is
also this offline gain was there it
wasn't significant compared to zero but
there was also no significant difference
between good so at this point we don't
know whether this offline gains are
sleep dependent or not but it's very
clear that these offline gains are
present I'm very strongly present for
this learning of a new control policy
but it's also very clear that if you
just adapt the all control policy and
visual motor rotation task you don't see
anything like this you're obviously
forgetting a stupid so to summarize now
what we have is we have recalibration of
an old internal model it seems to not
engage new processes at a time dependent
and also involve offline forgetting when
you go home and do something else we
have the phenomenon of learning a new
control policy which clearly depends on
additional time-dependent feedback
processes and might you offer I gain in
performance now for the last few minutes
of the talk I want to ask the question
well if we have these two types of
learning processes how does the brain
decide to do one or the other so what
are the variables that that determine
which kind of domain of learning where
so we had studied mirror reversals we
showed that this actually depends on
learning a new control policy with these
time-dependent processes
and we shown that a 40 or 60 degree
visual rotation is learned like your
calibration so so it involves some other
learning mechanism so what about a
rotation that is about 180 degrees so
light me reversal for if you want to if
your hand reaches to the left you're
going to see the cars are going to the
right the difference is only when you
reach to the upper left target your
cursor goes to the lower right here it
goes to the upper right so this is the
difference would they somehow be
different so first of all we replicated
the speed dependency on the mirror of
versal and plotting here now the
variable error on the on the on the
y-axis and what you see is that no speed
dependency in the baseline we see very
nice slowing and the nice speed
dependency of merging when you switch on
the mirror reversal but then over the
two days of training starts to automate
eyes st before and the same thing is
true for 183 visual rotation so there's
no difference between a mere reversal
and a 180 degree visual rotation in this
case so now we have a kind of nice
situation we know that 40 and 60 degree
of visual rotation are achieved through
recalibration 180 degree rotation the
nervous system kind of snaps out of that
and engages some new learning mechanisms
so there must be some transition point
where one goes into the other so this is
what we then try to do we implanted so
grab your rotation experiment where we
started with normal reaching so to reach
this target your hand goes to the left
your cursor goes to the left and then we
slowly started to impose the visual
rotation rotating in this case the Kurds
are clockwise to increasing degree and
this is the imposed rotation year and
the dotted line this is the hand
direction or the cursor direction it was
taken and so the adaptation here you see
that they don't fully adapt they kind of
fall behind a little bit and and this
went on till we imposed about a 100 45
degree rotation so 145 degree rotation
of the curse and the clockwise direction
in this case the subject had adapted to
55 degrees on average or so 60 degrees
on average and there was a 90 degree
error on the screen so up to then the
everything
like recalibration and then suddenly the
behavior of the subject this is group
average made it some some of the
discrete jump and that suddenly variant
induced and they kind of very quickly
jump to the right solution now totally
reversing their movement so it's a kind
of a discrete switch here I'm also
interestingly when we looked at the
reaction time has speed dependency of
the error we saw that up to this moment
up to this new point the lines were
completely flat the error increased
reaction time increased but there was no
evidence for speeding trade off starting
at that moment right after this band
suddenly we saw that speed accuracy
trade of kicking in meaning that there
might have been an additional process
like a selection process that then
reduced and increasingly automated so
the question is what triggers this
transition what triggers the system to
snap out of recalibration and go into
this learning of a new control so it
might be that it's the amount of
rotation so maybe 145 degrees which is
just too much um it might be that is the
size of adaptation meaning people might
adapt to 70 degree but not further this
what predict that people who adapt
faster should also switch faster finally
it might be the size of the error that
the subject sees on the screen meaning
when it hits 90 degree hour on the
screen it might be that then there's new
system switches so in this case people
who adapt very slowly should also switch
earlier because they see earlier larger
and so this is actually what we saw here
three subjects we could model their
switch point individually by fitting a
state space model that that models the
initial adaptation and also the switch
point in place as a model parameter and
then we can plot the the learning rate
so how good they adapted and how early
they switched against each other and
found a very healthy positive
correlation meaning that people who
learned a lot like this subject is they
stay very very close to the impost
rotation they were actually also the
subject that switched relatively late
here's a subject that didn't learn very
much that fell behind very quickly and
that one switched much earlier than this
so some evidence maybe it's the arrow
sighs it's really the driving signal for
the system to abandon at current eternal
now I want to leave you with the last
observation anything is quite intriguing
about how that comes about how does the
system figure out that there's something
better out there and so what we're
looking at here is the average
variability of the subjects in the
reaction time and also in the initial
reach direction over the course of the
experiment so the dashed line is kind of
the point that is the subject than
average switches you see that well
before the time it seems like that
subjects increase the variability in the
output so it seems like s things start
to go sour for the motor system and they
can't cope with that increasing rotation
it might be that the motor system now
starts injecting variability into their
behavior that that can serve as
exploration and wide show them that
there's actually something bad out there
that they might switch to them so that's
the summary an interest of time and it's
going to switch straight to
acknowledging the people who did all the
hard work this sebastin tell my PhD
student in my lab in daraa starvin who
is now at UC Berkeley who were really
driving force behind this and I want to
acknowledge my sources of funding I
thank you for your attention